[Music] It's
sudden, but I want you to think a little about
whether people are equal.
However, there is a continuation to
this.Equality is born at birth, but after that, the difference is whether you studied hard or not.The difference arises
there.Human beings are creatures that can think.
It's full of lies
It's a fact that inequality is also an unacceptable fact
I wonder if
you'll give me my
achievements
There is no public obligation.I'm
young, so
I
'd like to give up my genitals.Ah, why
is it?
Besides, the old
lady looks like she's having a hard time, so she's not interested in contributing to
society.  I'm fine
Thank
you
everyone Can someone
please give me a seat?
It's a school that aims to nurture young people who will support the future.It
advocates a 100% employment rate and a 100% higher education rate.
I was watching, but
what's
wrong,
you seemed to be unwilling to give up your seat, just like
me.
Nice to meet you,
student council president
Oreki-san, I'm going to study. On behalf of
all the students who entered our school this year
, I would like to extend my warmest welcome.
It's a word that takes a
meal.As you all know,
it's the pride of our country,
and it's achieved by the constant efforts of our graduates and current students.
A meritocracy
[music]
Another product
Hey shop Hmmm
Are you sitting next to
me?
It seems like the teacher hasn't come yet I
wonder if I
'm not a queen I don't even know my name
Thank you
So first I
want you to kick off and read Kirata Yosuke Feel free to read My
hobby is sports in general and I'm in the soccer club at this school  I'm planning to enter. I'm
sure everyone will be at the center of +.
Next is me.
Invite me more
and more I'm sure both men and women will become popular I can get along with anyone now It's not the time to criticize someone who is white with an aura
This self-introduction will determine where you stand in the class You
should aim for your arm  Katsuki is in the baseball club and people are super high tension and people are rice light It's okay with a
computer
No, I don't know if I can reach
you.
Yeah, I
can't
help it I'm going to introduce myself a little bit here For the sake of my
school life, I
'm Kiyotaka Ayanokoji.
Let's get along well,
Mara got
swollen, so what's next? What's your self
-introduction?  There
is no class change in this school
I will be in charge of you for 3 years until graduation First of all, let's hand out
our school's materials.
There are restrictions on leaving the premises and communication with the outside
world.Don't worry about the sand.The
paradise has all the facilities.You'll
be able to get everything you need for
life.Including Sagara.
Use the points held in the student ID terminal
At this school, you can buy everything with points The
points are transferred on the 1st of every month
Aichi points are 1 yen Dongfeng
You already have  Almost all of my 100,000 points have been paid out I
'll buy the same as I ordered I
was surprised at how much money I got
There are 25 students in each class, so there are 4 classes in each grade, so there are 300 students in the whole school.
Well, let's sit next to each other and say hello to each other from today on.
I think it's uncomfortable not to have one, but
Horiki and
Chairman Aoto, if
I'm not mistaken, buy cheap
ones.
I don't think you're good at socializing,
you're bad at talking
Yeah, I
think you're kind of like that,
yeah, but I don't feel the need to make friends in the first place.
Even though I'm giving you 100,000 yen a month,
you're a very naive learner Oh, you're a 1st-year d-class,
aren't you?
Thank you.
Hell
No. Pandan
After a while
, groups started to form within the class.
It
sure was hot, wasn't he
?
Kushida
: You remembered my name
.
I want to be friends with everyone at school Jun,
so I asked Mr. Horikita for his contact information, but
he refused
.
I want to be friends
with you too.I wonder if you can cooperate with me
.
In other words, it's a
system that determines cheat positions based on blood ties.
Even if I do, I won't pay attention This
is really a preparatory school run by the government
Isn't it supposed to be left to the autonomy of the students?
If you have specific requirements, I don't mind if
you ask me There must be a cafe in the shopping mall There are a lot of girls,
why don't you go there with
me?
I'm sorry, but you're right
.
[Music] It
's a lot of people. Did Horikita start it?
It's open over there.
It just so happened that
I entered alone Ah, I've
only just arrived If you have
Kushira-san, you don't need
me, huh? Horror Me and Kushida are just classmates, and
my relationship with you is the same, and in the
key  I can't get in
What do you want to do?
No, no,
Kushida What does that mean?
If we came here right after school, then the time they spent in this
cafe is too early to change when they were
alive.
Please
leave me alone I won't bother you in class
[music] It
's too late to be alone all the
time
All the winter feelings and hey, is it
really okay?
No, don't
worry
[music]
I wonder if we
can't be friends If I can't get along with the kids in my class, my goal is smart I
think Horikita is just special
Hichinoko Li  Ms. Honami at the Plus
Market I made a friend yesterday.Are you getting along with the students in the class you're closing in?
Yeah, because there are a lot of easy-to-talk-to people in my class,
but this school is amazing.
I got 10,000 yen
, and I think the size of the amount is a bit strange, but
well, it's called Somonjo points, so I'm likely to end up spending it, and I'm afraid I'll have a bad
sense of money.
I'm thinking, I
buy what I have to buy, but hey, it's the same as a kid who used soap detergent or other daily necessities.
I saw it,
or
rather, it was made into the basement, but that's really true, but
100,000 yen a
month.
Wasted like water In
class, teachers are laissez-faire.
I'll take my seat and start the morning homeroom
Sensei My
points haven't been credited, but aren't they supposed to be paid on the 1st of my month?
There's no doubt about it, there's
no possibility that this class was the only one
forgotten No one actually got credit j
[music]
You guys are really stupid.
The number of times I touched my phone
391 times In
January, I did a lot of things.In
this school, the grade evaluation of the class is reflected in the points that are transferred every
month.As a result of the assessment, you lost all the 100,000 points you had at the beginning
this month.  The points transferred are
zero, so
I'm going to live on zero yen
.
Thinking with common sense, nars
, leaving doubts as doubts
I probably told you on the day of the entrance ceremony,
this school is underperforming
You guys have a
rating of 0, so there's
no vacancies
[music]
uh
ano
Lee  Morning has flown by +6 and already there's stiffness on the ground.
[music]
[applause]
rar
amaran
me
[music]
ran
[applause]